how we doing move how you doing how you
doing I grew up watching mookie beds
back in Boston the dude was hitting
dingers your mother's gonna be so proud
of you she knows you're cooking for
moogie bad Stone today I'm stopping by
the set of food networks The Great Food
Truck Race I'm helping my friend Tyler
Florence judge a cooking competition and
I'm gonna buy a meal from the winner
with some help from my Wells Fargo
active cash credit card
everybody please say hello to Mookie
Betts
we miss your monster moves
your challenge today elevated ballpark
food I got food at the Ballpark all the
time my dad was actually the one that
was making the foods I was in the snack
bar eating all day every day mookie and
I are gonna walk around and taste every
single dish the dish that mookie likes
the most wins today's competition
let's go
what's going on guys how's everybody
doing
gotta do a version of a burger but maybe
we can use our meatball mix called the
mookie go do the mookie go-to throw back
to the ballpark days you know favorite
ballpark fool would have to be just a
really good cheeseburger Mookie
I got for you guys bacon cheeseburger
sliders with caramelized onions look how
juicy this is a good burger thank you
my go-to cheap meal uh would have to be
any type of dessert this bright pink
food
sugar just calls my name I come answer
it every single time this is my first
time ever having a crepe all right
Jamaican tacos ladies for you today we
have a hot honey fried chicken taco I'll
take my glasses off the CD
I would say la has some of the best food
they have a very good food scene here
what's going on boys I'm a loss of words
meeting you right now you just came from
Boston because your accent is going
right now right it's thick I think like
Mom's Sunday gravy all right you got to
put on for Boston now you know that
right oh yeah we got the mookies go to
Mookie's go-to is our version of an
Italian Smash Burger absolutely
delicious love the smash sauce oh yeah
get that sauce all over that's a good
burger you guys have a near and dear
spot right here because you're from
Boston
all right well welcome to uh my pain you
gotta pick a winner pick a loser I said
everything we tasted today we got three
all three of those amazing they did an
amazing job all right so let's do our
die time who's it gonna be he's coming
towards us congratulations boys
that's my roots I was there for a long
time so I know good food in Boston and I
had a taste earlier but now I want the
whole thing mookie played for our
favorite team now we get to cook food
for him it was great seeing all the
young ball players here at the field you
gotta hit it over the scoreboard bro we
gotta go over I love trying all that
amazing food and I love that I earned
unlimited two percent cash rewards on my
purchases with my Wells Fargo active
cash credit card you guys did it right
ooh that was good